the Joe Rogan experience the sad thing
is that the opioid epidemic was so often
started by people who were prescribed
drugs from their doctors and so that's
another thing there's a sea change
happening right now
is that there's all these new
regulations about what doctors are
allowed to prescribe they're trying to
discourage them from taking opiate from
prescribing opioids and that's a
positive shift I think for people who
are new patients right it's like if you
get a root canal you don't need some
crazy strong opioid you know you know
like to recover like a from a dental
procedure or whatever but the problem is
that now they're starting to take away
people's opioids when they've been on
them for a long term like I talked to
this woman from Colorado and she had a
disease I can't remember rheumatoid
arthritis or something she's been taking
opioids for for years and years and
years and now all the sudden the doctor
was like I can't give you these anymore
you have to take these classes about
alternatives to opioids you know and
they talked about acupuncture and yoga
and stuff like I know that's great
but she felt like just degraded you know
and and and studies have shown that
people if they get their opioid pills
taken away they're gonna turn to Street
heroin as a result and so the whole the
whole thing is it's insanely complicated
yeah you talked about that that there's
three waves right the first wave is the
pills second wave is Street heroin and
then third wave is fentanyl yeah exactly
and so so we're still facing the
repercussions from the first one and
that's what all these lawsuits that you
hear about in the news are all about and
the the the another scary thing is that
up until now people hadn't been asking
for fentanyl by name like we said it's
just put in other drugs but now in
places like San Francisco even st. Louis
fentanyl is starting to acquire a
reputation as a street drug because
longtime heroin addicts don't don't get
high anymore you know I mean they take
heroin and it just gets rid of their
withdrawal symptoms mmm and so fentanyl
will get them high again
and so people are starting to seek it
out
[Applause]